ถ้าพี่เอ๋น่ะสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
น้องอาร์ทตี้วันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษา
ไทยกันหน้าเรามาเรียนกันวันที่เท่าไหร่
ครับวันนี้เป็นวันที่ 3 วันพุธค่ะวันพุธ
วันนี้ไปก่อนเนาะวันพุธวันนี้วันพุธหน้า
วันพุธนะคะตอนวันที่ 3 ค่ะอ้าวอ๋ออ๋อวัน
พุธที่สามครับอะไรคะครู Arty อันนี้ใช่
ไหมครับนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายน
คริสต์นิกายอโนสีแดงหมดเลยนะคะครู Arty
มองเข็มไหมนักเรียนมองเห็นไหมครับอ่า 11
เนาะเดือนที่ 11 ใช่ครับเดือนที่ 11  5  5
เป็นวันแล้วตอนนี้เวลาก็ตอนนี้ก็พูดกี่
โมงไม่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนต้องพูดว่ากี่ทุ่มคะ
อ๋ออ๋อตอนนี้กี่ทุ่มกี่ทุ่มเป็นตอนกลาง
คืนเหรอครับใช่ค่ะค่ะบุ้มใช้ตอนกลางคืนมี
พระจันทร์เนาะอ๋อตอน
กลาง
คืน
รื่นกี่ทุ่มครับกี่ทุ่มตอนนี้น่าจะ
20:30 นผ่าใช่ครับตอนนี้
8:30 น 8:00 น
8:30
โอเคไม่รู้นักเรียนนอนหรือตื่นตอนนี้นอน
หรือยังครับ
ถ้ายังไม่นอนมามาเรียนภาษาไทยกับภาษารอดู
อาทิตย์ที่น๊อตตี้น้องแอนน้องอาร์ตี้กับ
ครูย
เอ๋พี่เอ๋ให้กับพี่เอ๋นะคะโอเคทุ่มครึ่ง
สีอะไรคะเนี่ยอ้าวรถรถสีเหลืองครับสี
เหลือง
รสสีเหลือง
คู๋รู้จักรถแต่ที่รถมีอะไรบ้างคะคุณน้อง
อดีตเดี๋ยวอ่ะ
ครูอาทิตย์ที่จะบอกหน้าว่ารถ B อะไรมี
อะไรบ้างคะนี่อันนี้นี่มีอะไรคะนี่เรียก
ว่าไปฝ่ายหน้าหน้านะคะหน้าหน้าด้านหน้า
อันนี้หน้า
แม่ครัวตี้หน้าคู๋อ๋อแต่ไฟอันนี้คือไป
ข้างหน้าได้ครับไปข้างหน้า
รถหน้ารถอ่ะไปหน้าไฟหน้ารถนะคะให้เขา
หนูไฟหน้าไฟหน้ามีกี่ดวงคะน้องอาร์ตี้ไป
หน้ามี 2 ดวงครับมีไปหน้าหนึ่งดวงไฟหน้า 2
ดวงอายครับมีไฟหน้า 2 ดวงอยู่ข้างขวาอยู่
ทางขวาใช่นี่บ้างหนึ่งดวงอยู่ทางซ้ายทาง
ซ้าย 1 ดู
ไฟหน้าทั้งหมดมี 2 ดวงใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับไฟ
หน้าทั้งกฎมี 2 ดวงแล้ว
อยู่ใกล้ๆไฟหน้า
กับไฟหน้า
[เพลง]
มีไฟอะไรคะตรงนี้เป็นไฟ
ไฟเลี้ยวครับฝ่ายเลี้ยวเลี้ยวๆครับริโน่
ไปเลี้ยวเวลาเราเปิดไฟเราก็เลี้ยวหน้าไฟ
เลี้ยวไปเลี้ยว
ก็มี 2 ดวงไฟเลี้ยวมี 2 ดวงๆครับไฟเลี้ยว
อยู่ข้างหน้าแล้วอยู่ข้างหลังไปเลี้ยวมี
มีข้างหน้าและมีข้างหลังด้วยงั้นไฟเลี้ยว
ก็มีทั้งหมด 4 ดวง
ใช่ครับมีคุณควงมี 4 ดวงอ่า
ก็ไฟเลี้ยวมีข้างหน้าอะสองดวงดวงโอ๊ยตาย
เลี้ยว 5 ครับเลี้ยวหลังสองดวงใช่ท้าย
ครับ
อ่ะ
ก็ไฟหรี่ไฟเลี้ยวไปเลี้ยวไฟเลี้ยวข้าง
หน้า 2 ดวงดวงใช่ครับนายเลี้ยวข้างหลัง 2
ดวงใช้กับมีไฟเลี้ยวๆซ้ายกับเลี้ยวขวา
เหรอคะครูอัญๆครับมีเลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวซ้าย
ทางนี้อ่ะอ่ะแล้วก็เลี้ยว
ขวาป๋า
ขวาสวัสดีกำลังคลิปคลิปคลิปว่า
ด้านนี้เลี้ยวขวาหรือด้านนี้เลี้ยวขวา
โอเคกลัวตี้ชีสว่าถ้ามีคนขาดค่ะถ้า
เนื้อหานั่งอยู่อันนี้เป็นขวา
แบน
สาย
เพราะฉะนั้นนี้ไฟเลี้ยว
ขวา
ขา R ด้านนี้เลี้ยวสาย
ลิเกอะติ๊ดเขียนอะไรนะ L กับ R ก็ได้นะ
เอ้ออ้าโอเคอ่ะข้างนี้เลี้ยวขวาหน้านี้
เลี้ยวซ้าย
58 เจก็มีข้างหน้าสองข้างหลังสองสาย 4
เริ่มมีอะไรอีกล่ะกู Arty ต้องมีคนนะค่ะ
ข้างหน้าเขาก็เปิดได้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับตรง
นี้ตรงนี้หน้าตรงนี้เป็นกระโปรง
กระโปรงกระโปรง
ว่าจะร้องรถอาครับหงส์รถไม่ใช่กระโปรงผู้
หญิงมันไม่ใช่ครับผมผู้หญิงเป็นยังไง
กระโปรงผู้หญิงเป็น 5 เป็นแบบนี้มีผู้
หญิง
สวมกระโปรงนะครับอ่ะกระโปรงผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงผมยาวเนาะที่ผมยาวด้วยว่าผู้หญิงอ้า
ก็จะมีกระโปรงชายมีประโปรงท้ายครับรถยนต์
ครับพูดเหมือนกันอ่า 555 ใครครับกระโปรง
หากระโปรงเหมือนกันค่าพี่รถเรียกว่า
กระโปรงรถใช่ไหมคะอ้าถูกต้องครับที่รถ
เรียกว่ากระโปรงรถหายวงรถนะคะในครับเปิด
ได้นะครับเอ่อใต้เปิดแอปที่ครู a นะคะก็
เห็นนะ
อัดตรงตรงๆตรงกระโปรงรถใช่ไหมคะอาบและๆ
ติดกับกระโปรงรถเป็นอะไรคะติ๊กคนอยู่หัว
คนน้องนี้อ๋อจงนี้ตรงนี้ตรงนี้เป็นกระจก 5
กระจกรถน่าจะจบกระจกหน้าเด็กกระจกลายครับ
กระจกหน้า
59 เพราะอยู่ด้านหน้าค่ะอายุหน้ารถใช่
ครับถ้าเป็นกระจกหน้า
ครับกระจกหน้ากระโปรงติดกันเนาะอ่ะแต่
เวลาฝนตกควรที่วาดเมฆมีฝนนะคะอ๋อถ้าฝนตก
ฝนตกก็จะมีฝน own  Heart นี้หามีฝนตกฝนตก
มีโอ้โหมองไม่เห็นไม่เห็นเวลาขับรถแล้วฝน
ตกมองไม่เห็นต้องมีอะไรคะต้องมี
ใช่ครับเป็นที่
ปัดน้ำฝน
มีกิ่ง Mini  2 นะคะที่ปั่นน้ำฝนมี 2 อัน
ครับนี่มี 2 อันมี
r&r ว่าฝนตกแล้วก็ไปน้ำฝนซ้ายๆครับหาปัด
ปัดปัดไปมาไปมาไปมาฮ่าๆๆๆๆๆ
ค่ะที่ปัดน้ำฝนเนาะอาตอนนี้นักเรียนก็รู้
จักอะไรบ้างนะคะรู้จักไฟหน้าอ้ามีไฟหน้า
ไปหน้านะคะอ่ะไฟเลี้ยวอ้ามีไฟเลี้ยวรอ
เดี๋ยวช้าย-เลี้ยวขวาโอเคแล้วก็อะไรอีก
ครับกระโปรง
กระโปรงรถ 5 ถูกต้องครับประโปรงรถ 5
พรุ่งนี้ครับกระโปรงรถอ่ะกระจกหน้ากระจก
น่าอยู่ตรงนี้นี่เองจบอ่ะแล้วก็
คลิปปัดน้ำฝนใต้ที่ปัดน้ำฝนหน้าคู่เอ๋
เก่งมากตัวเองทำได้จะได้จำได้นะคะๆที่ปัด
น้ำฝนเราก็กู Arty ถ้าลงมาข้างล่างจากไฟ
ไฟไฟหน้าครับจะไปหน้า
5 ลงมีอะไรอ่ะคะตรงนี้หรอกครับอ่ะ
ก่อนตรงนั้นนะคะตรงดังนั้นตรงนี้อะไรกับ
ไม่ใช่สปอยเลอร์ไม่ใช่อ่ะฮ่าๆๆเคยได้ยิน
สปอยเลอร์ชื่ออะไรโอเคอันนี้เป็นกันชน
หน้า
ใช่ครับเป็นกันชนชนหน้านี่ก็นี้เลยมีการ
ชนค่ะเวลาเวลารถชนชายครับ
เจอกันชนก่อนอ้าอันนี้ป้องกันป้องกันไม่
ให้ไม่ให้รถ
ข้างเยอะใจกับสนุกกันนี่แหละวิ่ง 5  cm
เป็นตัวการไว้การรไว้ได้ครับเป็นการชนกัน
ชนท้ายคะแล้วก็ตรงกลางของกันชนน่ะในภาพจะ
เป็น
[เพลง]
mg3 ตัวนี้เป็น
โลโก้
โอ้โฮอะครับโลโก้ของรถรถยนต์คันนี้โลโก้
เอม
อุ้ยดีถ้า 5 นะคะๆครับและนะแล้วลงมาข้าง
ล่างอ่ะคะข้างล่างตรงนี้อ่ะอ้าอันนี้เป็น
ป้ายทะเบียนครับอ้าป้ายทะเบียนถ้าๆๆครับ
จริงๆอ่ะตรงกระโปรงเปิดได้ไหมกระโปรงเปิด
ได้ครับได้แต่ตะวันนี้เราไม่เปิดน้องเรา
ปิดเอาไว้ฮ่าๆๆใจครับ
เราจะปิดเอาไว้นะคะเราไม่เปิดนะคะเหนื่อย
ครับวันนี้เราไม่เปิดกระโปรงเดี๋ยวพี่
อาร์ตี้พา
นักเรียนพาพี่เอกไปไปดูไปดูข้างหลังหลัง
รถดูข้างหลังก่อนไปดูข้างหลังคุณน้อง
อาร์ตี้เขาว่างเลยข้างล่างเลยข้างล่างตรง
นี้หน้าคืออะไรเนื้อหาตรงนี้เป็นล้อๆ
ใช่ครับอ่ะ
เป็นล้อหน้าเหมือนกันล้อหน้าอ่อนๆๆครับ
อ่ารอนาคมีกี่ล้อคะอ่าร้อนหน้ามี 2 ล้อ
อ่านิดหนึ่งร้อ
[เพลง]
ก็มีกันชนอยู่ด้านหน้าตรงนี้หน้าการนี้มี
ทะเบียนรถ 5 ทะเบียนรถอยู่ตรงกลางมี
ทะเบียนรถครับอะไรนะโลโก้เหรอหลงโก้ใช่
ครับเป็นโลโก้คนไทยก็พูดโลโก้นักเรียน
หรือไปที่พูดยี่ห้อยี่ห้อฮ่าๆๆพูดแล้วตอน
นี้พูดโลโก้
เดระก็ไฟเลี้ยวหน้านี่ไปเลี้ยวไปเลี้ยวก็
มี 2 ดวงอ่ะข้างหน้ามีสองนะคะครับมีไฟ
เลี้ยวขวาค่ะไฟๆเลี้ยวซ้ายหาก็มีอะไรอีก
ครับใกล้ๆกับแฟนอาจใกล้ๆกับไฟเลี้ยวก็จะ
เป็นไฟหน้าไฟหน้ามีกี่วันคะให้หน้าก็มี 2
ดวงสองดวงอะไรหายหน้าอะไรบ้างคะ 20 อยู่
ในหน้าขวาค่าไฟหน้าซ้ายนะครับอ่ะแล้วก็
ดวงขาด 2 ดวงนะคะเลยจากไฟหน้าไปข้างบน
เป็นอะไรนะคะข้างบนตรงนี้เป็นกระโปรงรถ
อ่าค่ะรถรถๆครับเราก็มีอะไรอีกคะกะ
ข้างบนอันนี้นี่วันนี้แพงป่ะจบฮ่าฮ่าก็จบ
หน้ากระจกหน้ารถหน้าไรครับแล้วก็มีซื้อ
อ้าอันนี้เอาไว้ใช้ตอนฝนตกหน้าอะไรคะ
เรียกว่าที่ปัดน้ำฝนครับน้ำฝนนะคะฝนกล้วย
ตีกับครู a ลืมข้างๆมีอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อข้างๆ
อันนี้หนีใช่ไหมครับนึกว่าอะไรคะ Man
กระจอก
แอบ
มองข้างเพราะมีอีก 2 อันใช่ครับมี 2 อัน
มี 2 อันเหมือนกันมีข้างขวา
และกระจกมองข้างซ้ายมองข้างขวามองข้างๆ
มองขวาใช่ๆครับๆ
อันนี้ข้างหน้ารถนะคะเดี๋ยวมีมีอีกมีข้าง
ไหนดีมีข้างหลังข้างหลังอ่างั้นเราไปดู
ข้างหลังนี่ไงข้างหลังหลังไม่เหมือนกัน
ห้างหลังมีไฟล์ด้วยมีไฟตรงไหนคะครับนี่มี
ไฟตรงนี้
หน้าเดี๋ยวไอ้อะไรคะเนี่ยกลัวตี้เปลี่ยน
เป็นปากกาสีแดง
ที่เห็นง่ายๆๆ
เรียกว่าใสอะไรคะตรงนี้เป็นไฟเบรคไฟเบรค
ใช่ครับเวลาเบรเราก็ไปนี้ก็จะติดหนีๆครับ
เรเป็นไฟเบรคค่ะอ่าแล้วข้างล่างติดกำลัง
เดทอังล่างติดกับไฟเบรคตรงนี้เป็นไฟถอย
หลังอาต๋อยหลังในครับเวลาเราถอยหลังอ๋อก็
ปิดไปใต้ใช้ครับกับ
กระพริบพริบกระพริบอาตอนข่อยหลัง
กลับริบ
มีไฟถอยหลังแล้วครูเอ๋ครับมีไฟเลี้ยวด้วย
เหมือนกันไปเลี้ยวอยู่ตรงไหนไฟเลี้ยวจะ
อยู่ข้างจะไปอยู่ที่เดียวกันกับไฟถอยหลัง
อาไปถอยหลังเป็นสีขาว
สีสีขาวในครับสีขาวใช่ครับไฟถอยหลังเป็น
สีขาวเวลาเปิดเป็นสีขาว
555 แล้วก็อ้าถ้าไฟเลี้ยวนะคะไม่ไป
เลี้ยวหน้าไฟเลี้ยวเวลาเปิดไฟเลี้ยงจะ
เป็นสีส้ม
ออกจะเป็นสีส้มชายครับมันดูเหมือนสี
เหลืองสีรถ
โอเค Way ไม่สีส้ม
อ้าโอเคใช่กับปี 2
เวลาที่เราเลี้ยว
โอเคนะครับถ้าเดี๋ยวซ้ายหรือว่าเลี้ยวขวา
เราก็จะลืมเปิดไฟเลี้ยวขาด
แล้วเห็นเหมือนมีอะไรจะเปิดติดกับไฟติด
กับไฟอะไรนะไปไฟเบรคอ่ะเป็นอะไรนะคะสีดำๆ
อันนี้อ่าสีดำเหมือนครั้งหน้าเลยเหมือน
ข้างหน้านี้เป็นกระจกอ่ะจกอะโสะคะกระจก
หลังมีหน้าหลังชายครับกระจกหลังหาใช้เขา
อันนี้กระจกหลังค่ะที่กระจกหลังเห็นมีสี
ดำๆกันเลยอ่าใช่ครับมีเหมือนกับหน้าอ่ามี
อันนี้เป็นที่ปัดน้ำฝนที่กระจกหลังที่
กระจกหลังใช้ครับ
น้ำฝนด้วยมี 1 อันมีอายุเดียวอันเดียวนะ
คะเดี๋ยวมามี 1 อันก็อ่าดีแล้วติดกับ
กระจกหลังลงมาข้างล่างอันนี้เป็นเป็นอะไร
คะเป็น
ประตูหลังอ๋อกูหลังใช้เปิดเปิดประตูหลัง
ได้ประตูหรือกระโปรง
ไม่มีกระโปรงกระโปรงหน้ากระโปรงหลังอ่า
โอเคไม่มีประโปรงหลังครูเอ๋ไม่ขับรถไม่
เข้าใจ
บางทีเรียกประตูบางทีเรียกกระโปรง
อ๋อโอเคเป็นประตูเข้าไปหาดูอยู่ตรงนี้อ่ะ
ประตูหลัง
[เพลง]
โอเคอ๋อมีกระโปรงหน้าไม่มีกระโปรงหลังแต่
ถ้าไม่มีครับ
แต่ถ้าอันนี้รถคันนี้ไม่มีกระโปรงหลังค่ะ
แต่ถ้ารถคันนี้
มีกระโปรงหลังอ๋อ
ออรถไม่เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันคันนี้ไม่มี
ประโปรงล่ะอันนี้มี
หาอันนี้มีอ๋ออ๋อถ้าเป็นรถแบบนี้ไม่เรียก
กระโปรงเรียกลายนี้เป็นประตูชายครับอ่า
โอเคโอเคคู๋ไม่เข้าจะ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
มีครับแล้วพี่ลงมา me  me  me  me  Number
3 สีขาวๆอันนี้เป็นทะเบียนมาถึงหน้า
ทะเบียนรถทะเบียนรถมีข้างหน้าแล้วก็ไอ้
ข้างหลังอ่ะอ่ะมีข้างหน้าแล้วก็ข้างหลัง
ด้วยนะฮ่าๆนี้เป็นทะเบียนหลังนะครับ
แล้วสีดำๆคืออะไรคะสีดำๆสีดำอันนี้เป็น
อาการชนหลังกันชนหลังๆครับการชนหลังด้าน
หลังอาหารกันชนหลังมีสีแดงด้วยอ้าสีแดง
อันนี้เป็นฝ่ายเหมือนกันค่ะไปเบรคไฟเบรค
รีสอร์ทมีสีเหรอได้มีไฟเบรคอยู่ด้านบนค่ะ
และไฟเบรกด้านล่าง
ๆครับ
น้าทักข้างล่างบางทีมองไม่เห็นใช่ไหมคะ
อาหารด้วยอ้ามีทั้งบนด้วยโอเคก็มีไฟเบรค 4
นะมีรถคันนี้นี่มีไฟเบรค 4 เลยนะคะๆครับ
พี่ไฟเบรก 4 ดวงไฟเลี้ยวก็ 4 นาทีอ่ะหน้า
มีได้ล้อคู๋อ่าล้อต้องมีล้อที่ร้อนหน้า
สองล้อแล้วก็มีล้อหลังกี่ล้อค่ะค่ะมีล้อ
หลังสองล้อ Oz นี่ครับหน้ารอหลังสองล้อ 1
ร้อ
ก็เพราะว่ารถยนต์เนาะไม่ใช่มอเตอร์ไซค์
อีกคะสำหรับเดี๋ยวเราทวนก่อนนะคะก็จะมีมี
อะมีคู๋นะครูเอ๋พูดนะคะครับอ้าเช็ค IQ
คู๋นะคะมีกระจกหลังใครครับมีกระจกหลังมี
ที่ปัดน้ำฝนหน้านี้ที่ปัดน้ำฝนอยู่นี่
ครับมีไฟเบรคข้างบอยอ้าอยู่นี่ยังบน 1 ใบ
เบรคสองข้างบนครับก็มีไฟเบรคข้างล่างสาย
เบรคอยู่ข้างล่างตรงนี้นี่หนึ่งดวงสองดวง
ว้าวเก่งมากมีประตูหลังประตูหลังใช่ครับ
มีประตูหลังอยู่ตรงนี้ถ้า
ประตูหลังแล้วก็มีกันชนฉันทนนี่กันชนมีสี
ดำกันชนหลังกันชนหลังตายครับแล้วก็มีร้อน
หลังสองล้อๆถูกต้องครับมีล้อหลังซองล้อ
ข้างบนมีอะไรแหลมๆฮ่าๆๆอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับๆ
นี่นี่เป็นเสาอากาศ
เสาอากาศเวลาเราขับรถขับรถเราฟังฟังเพลง
ฟังเพลงอ่าๆ f  m  a  m  Radio  r4 ดู
ทีวีได้ไหมดูทีวี
โค๊ดเตี้ยดูทีวีไม่ได้
ปวดแต่
ถ้าเด็กๆใช่ไหมนั่งงานต่างๆดู TV หา
เขามีเสาอากาศที่อยู่ข้างบนอ่ะข้างบนมี
เสาอากาศหนาวอากาศ
มีอะไรผิดที่รถวันนี้เอ๋เอ๋พี่ร้อนเรื่อง
รถนะคะ 5 เวลาเวลาเราจะขับรถเราจะขึ้นไป
ในรถทางไหนครับแล้วนะ 400 เดี๋ยวๆตอนนี้
ครูเห็นกระโปรงหน้าเห็นกระจกหน้าแล้วเห็น
ประตูค่ะหนังเปิดมาดูข้างหลังเข้าไปได้
ไหมคะโอเปิดประตูข้างหลังเอ่อไม่ได้ครับ
ไม่ได้ข้างหลังไม่มีไม่มีที่นั่งขับหน้า
ต้องเข้าต้องเข้าด้านข้างครับเพราะด้าน
ข้างด้านข้างอ่ะงั้นรถก็มีข้างขวาข้าง
ซ้ายใช่ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับถูกต้องมีข้างขวา
และก็มีข้างซ้ายด้วยใช้นี้น่าจะเข้าและ
ขวาก่อนมั้ยคะเนี่ยะใช่ครับอันนี้ทางขวา
ข้างขวา gogoey เห็นแล้วเห็นประตูอ่า
อ้าอันนี้ประตูประตู
2 ประตูใช่ไหมคะค่ะมีประตู 2 ประตูใช่
ครับของขวานะข้างขวาอ่าข้างขวามีประตู
หน้าขัดถูหน้าอันนี้หน้ารถค่ะนิราง loss
ค่ะอ่านี่ประตูหน้า
ดูหน้ารถพูดอะไรคะหลังรถประตูหลัง
แล้ว
เดี๋ยวปาร์ตี้ตรงประตูทั้ง 2 นะค่ะมีอะไร
เล็กๆเป็นอ่าอันนี้นี้เป็นอ่ามือจับประตู
น้อขอเชิญกราบระดับแล้วก็เปิดออกมาค่ะใช่
ครับอ่าใช้มือจับตรงนี้มือจับถ้าเราก็
เปิดออกมาหาใช้มือจับแล้วก็เปิดประตู
และแล้วประตูน่ะมีสีเหลืองแล้วข้างบนสีดำ
อ้าวทั้งบนสีดำตรงนี้เป็นกระจก
กระจกกระจกประตู
555 หน้าต่างใช่มั้ยอ๋อ
ได้ครับได้เราหน้าต่างหน้าต่างรถผู้ตาย
แล้วหรือกระจกรถกระจกรถหน้าต่างรถได้ทั้ง
2 แบบได้ทั้ง 2 แบบบางคนพูดอ้ะอ้ะรถ
กระจกอ่ะเป็นศพอาพูด
และเปิดหน้าต่าง
หน้าต่าง
คนไทยเรียก 2 แบบ 2 อย่าง R  2 แบบเลยค่ะ
แล้วก็มีร้องใช่ไหมคะมีลาวมีหรออุ้ยเรา
รู้จักและเรารู้แล้วอันนี้ล้อค่ะอะไรครับ
รอหน้าข้าเก่งมากล้อหน้าวะแล้วอันนี้รอ
อะไรครับร้อนหลังถ้าถูกต้องครับมีล้อหลัง
แล้วตรงกลางของล้อเป็นอะไรค่ะตรงกลางขอ
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่าตรงนี้เป็นล้อแม็ก
ออร้อมาให้ครับล้อแม็กนะมีล้อแม็กอยู่ใน
ห้างไหนบ้างในไปครับ
แต่ว่าท่านล้อส่วนนอกเป็นยางใช่ไหมคะอ้า
นี่เป็นยางเป็นยาขอโทษๆน่าจะปูทีมละโอ้โห
ยางแรกไปไม่ได้เลยยังแต่ใช่ครับเท่ากับกู
ทีมนะครับสวัสดีคะครับผู้เห็นตรงสีเหลือง
เหลืองมีกลมๆอ๋อตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะตรง
นี้นะคะพรุ่งนี้เป็นที่เติมน้ำมันตรงนั้น
คือเป็นเออ
มันกลมแบบเนี้ยแล้วก็ได้ครับเปิดได้เปิด
ได้แล้วเราก็เปิดอาหาเปิดแล้วกับปิด
ใช่ครับ
นี่พี่เติมน้ำมันค่ะ
แล้วน้ำมันใส่ลงไปตรงนี้ขาขาวหน้าเติมน้ำ
มันน่ะได้ครับโอเคก็ด้านขวาก็จะมี
อาตู 2 บานมีประตูออกบางประตูข้างหลังได้
ครับก็มีหน้าต่าง
2 บานบังมานแล้วก็มีอะที่จับมือจับประตู
มือจับประตูเอาไว้เปิดประตูใช้เราก็มีอะ
อะไรนะที่ใส่น้ำมันไม่ตรงไหนอ้อตรงนี้อ่ะ
ป๋าเป็นฝาถังน้ำมันหาตัวฝาเป็นฝาใช้งับ
เป็นฝาถังน้ำมันเปิดได้เกิดน้ำมันใส่ทราย
ครับ
พี่
ขับรถไปได้เลยถ้ามี
อีกไหมคะมีอีกไหมมีมีอีกครับๆกูอยากดูใน
รถไหมครับอยากดูอีกฝั่งหันอยากดูอีกฝั่ง
นึงออกก็มีไว้คะด้านหนึ่งด้านซ้ายใช่ไหม
ครับอ่าด้านนี้ด้านขวาเราไปดูด้านซ้ายกัน
น่ะนี่มาแล้วหารๆคล้ายๆกันนะพาสายเหมือน
ท่านขึ้นเหมือนกันมีประตูหน้าหน้าเหมือน
กันค่ะมีประตูหลัง R5 แล้วก็มีร้องอ้ามี
ล้อหน้าและมีล้อหลังเหมือนกันใช้ครับกู
Arty คู๋น่ะรู้ข้างนอกและข้างในรถมีอะไร
กูเองยังไงอ่าเดี๋ยวเราเปิดประตูเปิด
ประตูเข้าไปดูข้างในกันนะครับอ่านี่
อันนี้แหละครับว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เป็นวงกลม
กล่อมๆนมกลมๆ O7 นะอ่าร้านนมมาเรียกว่า
พวงมาลัย
พวงมาลัยให้กับพวงมาลัยอ่าเวลาเราขับรถ
เราก็จำห่วงมาลัยแล้วเรื่องซ้ายเลี้ยว
ซ้ายแล้วก็หมุน
หมุนไปทางซ้ายอ่าหมุนพลังป๊ายถ้าเลี้ยว
ขวาก็จะเลี้ยวขวาก็น่าหมุนไปทางขวามากมาย
ครับ R นิดเดียว
ตายอ้ะก็หมุนไปต่างสายๆค่ะเลี้ยวขวาก็
หมุนไปทางขวา
กูอันตี้
คู๋ไม่เข้าใจไอ้ตรงเลี้ยวซ้ายพวงมาลัยมี
มีตรงนี้ค่ะแล้วมีอะไรอ่ะพังสลายตรงนี้
ตรงนี้ล่ะครับให้ค่ะคืออะไรก็ลองออกอ่ะ
ลองนี้ตรงนี้เอาไว้กลับเสียงเพลงเอาขับรถ
เราฟังเพลงไปด้วยค่ะไปด้วยเราก็ใช้มือจับ
ตรงนี้มือเราจับพวงมาลัยไว้เพราะเราขับรถ
แต่เรามีนิ้วโป้งนิ้วโป้งเหลืออยู่นิ้ว
โป้งไม่ได้จับหรือโป้งมากดอ๋อกด
ฟังเพลงเปลี่ยนเพลงอ่ะเปิดเพลงให้ดั่งคืน
เปิดเพลงให้เมาลงนะฮ่าๆๆกูเองไม่รู้จัก
จริงๆนะไม่คุยรู้
ตายขาวๆขอบคุณถ้ารักข้างล่างอ่ะคะข้าง
ล่างอ่ะนี่นี้ค่ะที่ติดกับตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับค่ะสามารถเปลี่ยนเพลงได้
อาบเลื่อนเพลงไปเพลงที่อีกหนึ่งเลื่อนไป
เพลงที่ 555 เพลงที่ 6 เลื่อนเพลงได้ๆ
ครับดีมากดีมากนะคะแล้วตรงกลางตรงมาอัน
นี้คืออะไรอ่ะตรงกลางตรงตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่อ่ะต้องนี้เป็นพวงมาลัยไม่มีอะไรไม่มี
อะไรให้ครับพี่ทรายเฉยๆครับแต่ตรงนี้มีมี
อะไรคะนี่
ถ้าเรากดตรงนี้กดตรงนี้จะมีเสียงดังเป็น
เสียงแปรอ๋ออ่าใช่ครับเล่นเสียงแปลใช่
ครับอ่าเสียงแตรดังๆออกมาถ้าเรากบหน้า
เวลาเข้าเต็มๆๆน่าเป็นเสียงแปลโลกนี้ถ้า
อามีรูปแลอยู่
โหคู๋เข้าแต่ละตอนนี้กลมๆเนี่ยเรียกว่า
พวงมาลัย
ไม่ครับเวลาเราจับนิ้วโป้งเราว่างเราก็กด
เพลงได้อ่าใจเนื้อเพลงได้เวลาข้างหน้า
คนไม่แล้วก็ๆอ้ารับบทแปลได้มีแสดังใกล้
ครับโอเควันนี้กูอาจจะขับรถได้ใช่ไหมข้าง
ๆแล้วยายแล้วแต่ต้องมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมอ่ะ
ต้องมีมีอย่างอื่นอีกนะครับอะไรคะมีอัน
นี้อันนี้อันนี้ก็อยู่ในรถด้วย 5 อยู่
ข้างนานคด kuai รู้นี้อะไรครับภาษาป 5
เกลียดอ่ะถูกต้องครับนี้คือเกียร์แป๊บๆกู
เองไม่รู้ว่า p คืออะไรอาหารอะไร N อะไร
ดีคืออะไรดีคืออะไรฮะโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวกลัว
ตี้เยาว์ให้ฟังได้ไหม 5 ได้ครับเดี๋ยว
กลัวที่จะบอกนะครับผัวพี่พี่ 5 ตอนนี้
อยู่ที่ตัว P  E มีค่ะนิเกียร์ตำแหน่งนี้
อยู่ที่ตัว P คืออะไรแปลว่า
จอดจอดให้ครับขับไม่ได้รถไม่ไปไม่ไปรถจอด
อยู่ที่จอดพี่เบียร์ไปไว้ที่พี่อายครับ
เลื่อนไปไว้ที่ปีหน้าเอามานะอย่างนี้ถ้า
มาอยู่ตรงนี้ตรงนี้จะเป็น
หอยหลังถอยหลัง
คู๋แน่ฟังกูอธิบายก่อนว่ามีอีกขวากับซ้าย
กูเอกก็กินอ่าเนี่ย
ในอายให้อายท่านจะเลี้ยวต้องเลี้ยวหมุน
พวงมาลัยหมูหมุนพวงมาลัยให้ครับอ่ะข้อ 5
เลื่อนเกียร์มาที่อาจะเป็นถอยหลัง up  of
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะถอยหลานทรายไปหลังอ่ะอ่า
น่าโอเค
แล้วก็จะเรียนมาตรงนี้ล่ะถ้าเลื่อนมาที่ n
ตรงนี้รถจะอยู่ที่นิ่งๆรถจะไม่ไปรถอยู่
นิ่งๆหรอใช่ครับอยู่นิ่งๆหารถไม่ไปค่ะ
อาหารแล้วถ้าอันนั้นมันอะไรอีกอันนึงอ่ะ
ddr5 ตัวนี้ก็คือ
อาอาอ้าอันนี้เป็นการขับไปข้างหน้ารถวิ่ง
ไปข้างหน้าต้องเลื่อนมาตรงนี้ค่ะถ้า
ครับไปเร็วๆอันนี้ๆไปเร็วก็นี้ไปช้าก็อัน
นี้อ่าที่เดิมใช้ก็ต้องมี 1  2  3 ไม่มี
ไม่เหม็นออโต้ใช่ไหมอ่ะท่อง
เที่ยว Auto แล้วอีกตัวนึงคะตัว B ตัวเอง
ที่
ไม่ใช่เด็กนี่ไม่ใช่เพลงเนี่ยหาตัวนี้
เวลาที่เราขับรถขึ้นภูเขา
R2 ใช้เกียร์หนีได้นะครับค่ารถคืนภูเขา
เรียกว่าเกลียดอะไรคะพาสารอาจเป็นภาษาไทย
เรียกว่าเกียรติต่ำทอดเกียร์ต่ำใช้กับ
ทวิงช้ามีช้า
ๆที่เตียงต่ำแต่ขึ้นสูง 5 ๆลงก็ได้ลงก็
ใช้เกียร์ต่ำอ้ออ้อเวลาวิ่งช้าชักวิ่งช้า
แปลว่าความเร็วความเร็วต่ำๆความเร็วต่ำ
ไม่ใช่ต่ำอ๋อโอเคกับฟันลืมใช้ความเร็วนิด
หน่อยนะคะใช่ใช่กูเขา V หมอเขาๆครับค่ะ
เข้าใจแล้ว
นะคะมีอะไรอีกค่ะครูอ่ะเออโอเคมีอะไรอีก
นอนที่เวลาเราจะหมดวันที่เวลาจะหมดหน้ามา
ดูอันนี้
ครับอะไรคะหนึ่งสองสามสี่มี 3 อันเลยอัน
นี้เป็นอะไรคันเร่งอันเร่งได้ครับถ้าเรา
อยากจะไปเร็วเราให้เร็วเราต้องเหยียบขอ
อันนี้มือนะคะนักเรียนเท้าให้เท้ายืนไม่
ได้นะคะใช้เท้าเหยียบ
[เพลง]
เท้าสวนตีน
ใส่รองเท้าด้วยนี่เดินเท้าแล้วหาวอิบ 5
เหยียบคันเร่งค่าเหยียบเยอะเหยียบลงไป
เยอะไปเร็วๆว่าไงครับเหยียบนิดเดียว
เหยียบเบาเบาๆเบาๆรถวิ่งช้าช้าๆๆๆครับเป้
ติดกับคันเร่งเป็นอะไรหานี้อันนี้เป็น
เบรคเป็นเบรคหน้าเป็นเบรคหน้านี้ไร้
เหยียบเบรกพับรถหยุดรถหยุดได้ครับเบส
กับเบรคคืออะไรกับเบรคอันนี้เป็นที่วาง
เท้า
2 อันนี้ใช้เท้าขวาอ๋อส่วนเท้าซ้ายไม่
ได้ใช้เท้าซ้ายวางไว้ตรงนี้ไม่งานไปทำ
กว่าห้างไว้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
โอเควางเท้าโอ้ยอะไรอีกไหมอ่ะไม่มีใช่นะ
อ่ามีผมไม่เกี่ยวนะอ้า
อันนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ้าอันนี้เป็นที่เปิดฝา
กระโปรง
กระโปรงกระโปรงหน้าอ๋อดึงตรงนี้ดึงปืนป่า
ก็พองนะเกิดออกใช้หน้าเอกก็ช่างมองอ๋อ
เข้าใจแล้วใจแล้วค่ะนักเรียนเข้าใจแล้ว
ครูเอ๋วันนี้เรียนเรื่องรถนะคะ R ครับที่
เวลารถจะไปอ่ะมีอย่างนี้แล้วรถไปไม่ได้
ต้องมีอีกหนึ่งอย่างไรห่าๆครับต้องมีอัน
นี้
มันมีเรียกว่าอะไรขาดไหมเรียกว่าแม่อ้าใจ
ครับกุญแจรถกุญแจรถนะคะครับคุณแจรถคะใช่
แล้วค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้ครู Arty กับครูเอ๋
ก็มาสอนเกี่ยวกับเรื่องของรถนะคะไปเขารถ
แต่ว่าวันนี้ช่วงเวลาหมดแล้วนะเดี๋ยวครู
อาเที่ยวคู๋ต้องไปก่อนนะคะได้ครับเดี๋ยว
เรามาเรียนกันใหม่คราวหน้าค่ะก่อนไปนะคะ
อย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด Subscribe
Comment ให้ครู Arty กับครูเอ๋ด้วยนะคะ
ได้ครับพรุ่งนี้ไปก่อนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณ
มากครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋อ่าพอดีนะเมีย
ครับผม 100 บาทแล้ว